Thanks well yeah indeed so I think
discovering of the novel motives is one
of those classic problems in Banff Oh
Mattox has been around for more than 20
years and solution go back to the 90s
and I will share one of them and then
still we're missing good algorithms and
to apply to the data and just to give an
outline before I start so I'm going to
first cover one of the classic
algorithms then me Marguerite m and two
will be a reminder and guess for maybe
some or most of you if you know the
algorithm and also about expectation
maximization then in the second part I'm
going to move to and discuss and new
technologies and the kind of data that
they provide us and also the
computational problems and solution and
that arise from these new technologies
and if I go too fast through the two
parts the first to pass deny or so I've
kept some slides at the end about
sequence designs problem that arrives
from these technologies and I'll totally
theoretical so maybe we'll be able to
discuss those if not then I discussed
those in the workshop on gene regulation
so I'll start with the first part and I
just wanted to say so
these parts are independent so if you
have a learning breakdown in one of
those then you can still get the other
part oh if you fall asleep and it's
after lunch and you already know the
material so let's start with the novel
motif discovery using expectation
maximization and I think it will be it
will be a good reminder because e/m is a
great algorithm it's very useful and
many bioinformatic problems use it in
the slides taken from the computational
genomics class a terrible university
given by a professor or the chyron and
juan chamula and so i don't think i have
to go over this slide because Nadal gave
an introduction and motivation of one
and a half hours but why we want to be
able to identify the binding sites where
the protein bind and control gene
expression and want to model those so we
can predict new binding sites and
understand the regulatory mechanism
behind transcription factor binding and
I think the story that complicates
things about the binding of protein to
DNA is that it does not bind to a single
sequence it may bind to several
different sequences so here for example
we have the protein and the DNA molecule
and we see that the protein prefers to
bind to this sequence ACGT GC a and
let's say it has some intensity 100 in
some units if we make a mutation in that
sequence so if it is if it appears in
the genome with some mutation it may
still bind it but we fare a lesser a
smaller intensity so both of these can
serve as binding sites but one is
stronger than the other in terms of
binding intensity you can also make a
different mutation in the same position
and we'll get a different intensity so
there are different potential binding
site sequences that serve as the binding
site and it can be also that we make two
mutations and that and then we will all
we lose any binding and it's the
intensity as is the background binding
so so what we would like is to model
these to have a model that will be able
to give us an ability to predict the
binding site and intensity to the
genomic sequences of DNA sequences in
general so what are the computational
models that are common and used and to
represent the binding preferences and
and the world motif is is used to
describe the set of binding site
sequences the together constitute this
motif so the first and most simple model
would be a consensus string so we can
just say okay this is the string that
the protein binds and that's it but we
have seen that this is very limited
because in reality does bind different
sequences with mutation and variations
so we can add relax the definition and
allow it to have up to D mismatches so
in this example we can say that we allow
up to one mismatch and then we have
different binding site but if you
remember the example I just showed in
the previous slide it could be that some
mismatches are allowed and
the protein would still bind but if we
have a mismatch in a different position
it may not bind for example it may be
that the first G is very important for
the binding of the protein so we must
average it in that position and allowing
enemy's match and mismatch at any
position does not follow these words so
we can extend the model of the consensus
string with up to D mismatches into a
model that we call a degenerate string
so here we are using characters and each
characters does not represent a single
nucleotide but a subset of the
nucleotides ACGT these are called apart
characters and for example here we have
a W which represent a ot and B which
represents C G ot so we can see these
kind of variations in the binding site
but we do insist on having GG and 80 in
those positions then when we look at the
sequences we can identify those binding
site but still this model is also as a
limit is also limited and for example in
the example I have shown one variant
reduced the binding to 80 while another
variant in the same position reduced the
binding to intensity of 50 and this does
cannot be modeled using a degenerate
strength because we assume that they
distribute uniformly that is 80 options
distribute uniformly and appear with 50%
for each nucleotide so we can extend
this model into what is called the
position-specific scoring matrix or
position weight matrix it has a
different name and this is the most
common and used model currently and used
in any tool that ones that does
prediction of new binding sites so what
we have in this matrix we have four rows
each corresponding to different
nucleotides and the number of columns
corresponding to the position in the
binding sites in each one of those
columns we have weights for each of the
nucleotides this can be for example in
this illustration the probability of
observing that nucleotide in that
position so for example in the first
position we can have we can see we
usually see T with 90% chance and we see
a with 10% probability and then
never observe SC ology so this is the
example given here and we can also get a
score for each binding site so we can go
over the six Murs in the sequence we can
multiply the probabilities and get a
score and see that and say that if the
binding site is over the threshold
in this example 0.09 it is considered a
binding site and and this is a very
useful model and I think that there is a
term I'm afraid that says that all
models are wrong but some are useful so
this is one of those useful models and
it has been shown to be an anthro model
and what is what is wrong about this
model is that there is an inherent
property of Independence between the
columns so if we have a contribution
from this column it is completely
independent from the contribution of
observing the nucleotide in the next
column and it is known that there is
dependency between position in protein
DNA binding site and but still it is
very useful and and the case as well we
do have these dependencies are very few
at least from what we know from the
current data that we have so for most
protein it works very well and still
it's it's been used in and still being
used in all of the band 4matic pipelines
and one of the reason why the model is
so successful and I think I heard Gary
storm was saying that in ice and being
Berlin in 2013 that one of the things
that pushed the PWM to be so popular
it's the interpretable visualization
that accompanies each matrix so we have
a way to visualize the preferences in
each position using the sequence logo as
it is called and here we have the
distribution given for each position so
for example here we have 50 54 cnz cng
so we have of the occupancy of the
height given to see and half given to G
and what is the height of each character
that's the opposite the inverse of the
entropy so as the position gets more
strict the letter is higher for example
in the first position we have 90% given
to tea so see that this is a
hi character in a more uniform position
we see that the letter is very low so
that way we can get a sense of how
strict it is positioning and the exact
calculation sorry would be of that
height it's called the information
content is the sum is actually
subtracting the entropy from two that's
log PR all right some in Deauville ACGT
that's the height of each position so
that's the pwm and now moving to more
extensive models so for example the kml
model that makes no assumption so we can
model any dependency between position we
just have all possible k-mers and for
each came here we have a binding score
so that way we can express whatever
dependency there is in the data so what
is the limitation in the model it's the
number of parameters so you can imagine
that if the length of the model escape
will need fall to decay parameters as
opposed to this model well in each
column we have three parameters if it is
distribution of all parameters we need
three K or four K parameters so this is
a much more compact model and when we
have this and if is exponentially
greater than the PWM which is the risk
of overfitting with when we don't have
enough samples in the data that's why
the PWM is still as a lot of success
compared to the camer model in addition
what's missing for the camera model is
that interpreted visualization right
even in the end you want to sail your
model you want to say something that you
can look at and understand what's going
on when you have a list of cameras and
scores it's it's very hard to understand
what's going on behind the TF binding
and there are other models that are in
between the position weight matrix and
the cable modem so supplements the PWM
in the form of dinucleotides
contribution so most of the dependencies
that have been observed in protein DNA
binding are between two positions and
mostly adjacent positions so we can just
add features that curve
those dependencies other suggestin are
using DNA shaped features so this is
something that coming from rimmel Ross
lab in USC and these features tell us
how the DNA base pairs are standing one
x to the other and they also have an
effect on DNA binding okay so this
covers the modern what I'm going to show
in the next slides and in the
presentation I'm going to focus on this
model and algorithms that learn the PW
model to represent protein DNA binding
how much information is there in the
camer models in biological sense that
that is captured that's not and I can
like give a measurement in a UC for
example like how well they improve the
prediction of - yeah I mean new data
which is high-throughput allows you to
infer these camera models so I mean it
improves significantly so maybe the
average AUC for camera model would be
2093
for the PWM would be 88 something like
that so I mean just I don't have the
numbers but it's something in those I
mean I think there are definitely more
accurate when you have good training
data so that's the problem so I'm
talking specifically about PBM and high
throughput selects which I'm going to
talk about later and so there the camera
model is very successful but when we in
now take the camera model and apply to
in vivo data we don't see the same
improvement and actually the pilgrim
performs better so I mean and taking in
vitro models and and predicting in vivo
binding is a big problem in in the field
yeah so I'll discuss it a little bit
later
yeah so in the past most of these models
were about six eight ten base pairs not
longer but with more data we do observe
an effect of the sight position and
flanking positions in addition to the
core positions so so the technologies
are improving and allowing us to to
measure the effect of this sight
position but yeah we would like them to
be as long as possible but so currently
I yeah it's still an open question how
long do we need the models to be yeah
but we indeed them in like the classic
the dog mind the past that it's only six
or eight base pairs is no longer valid
yeah so if we are given a set of binding
sites and then creating the PWM the
motive profit profile is very easy right
we have the set we can just look at each
position and construct the PWM according
to the frequencies so we can say this is
a probability of a 3 to 3 over 5 and
this is 2 over 5 60% and 40% and we can
also get the consensus very easily by
looking at the nucleotide as the highest
frequency at each position but we are
rarely given the set of binding sites so
if you have no doubt this morning we
talked about different technologies that
measure the binding of the protein to
the DNA they give us maybe 300 base
pairs or 200 base pairs of well the
protein is binding but we don't know the
exact binding sites so this is a task of
taking binding sites and making them a
profile from them is rarely the case and
we need more and more sophisticated
algorithm to end the long sequences so
this is what motif discovery is usually
like for protein DNA binding and for
discovering a new binding site so first
what we need to identify is what is the
set of coagulated genes or the set of
sequences in which we want to find the
motif this can be given from gene
expression profiles here it's a kind of
obsolete it says microarrays but of
course these days we can use our Nasik
to measure gene expression and we can
identify in class
those genes that have similar expression
profits sense they have similar
expression profiles we may assume that
they are regulated by the same protein
the same transcription factors is
binding the promoter regions and so we
can look for a motif in the promoter
sequences another way is to have the
location of binding using chip
technology so here it says chip chip and
indeed in the past we would measure the
binding using microarray that is a
design of the promoters these days and
we can use chip SEC likely all mentioned
and also Nidal today so the chips that
gives us the occupancy of the binding in
the genome in vivo in resolution of
about 300 base pairs now I want to
identify the short motif in those set in
that set of sequences and we can also
take functional functional groups and
assume that they are regulated by the
same transcription factors then we take
the sequences and what is left is for us
the computational biologists to develop
a motif discovery algorithm and to get
these nice sequence logos and PWM that
represent the binding preferences of the
protein so this is the problem that I'm
going to show solutions for in the next
slides now what makes this problem such
a big challenge in so difficult so first
binding sites are short and degenerates
so or maybe they are long it depends but
they are usually between 10 to 20 base
pairs and they've the generously they
are not fixed it's not a single sequence
the constant sequence they have a lot of
variation in them so we need to find a
motif with those variations second that
promoters that they are usually in are
long and complex so in the promoters
themselves the distribution of the
nucleotides outside of the binding site
it's not a uniform distribution it's not
even a fixed resolution among all the
other nucleotides and position the
promoter the promoters may have other
elements and other repetitive regions
which can also look like a motif so this
is another challenge in addition the
cells search space is huge so for
example if we want to consider
all sequences all motifs of length L we
need to consider fall to the L sequences
and we might want we might want to
include all mismatches up to D
mismatches so we'll have to multiply it
by L of LD and this is the space of
motifs that we want to consider
so just fold that it's becoming quite
huge exponential in L in the length of
the motif and also the number of
sequences that we take in the promoter
sequences that we look at the motif in
is also a big number could be thousands
of promoters or chipset peaks of length
a 300 base pairs and the data is noisy
so anything that we get from in vivo
from the cell it has noise in it and
it's not accurate that can also mislead
our motive finding algorithm so here is
an example of what is exactly motif
finding given these sequences so if we
implant a motive let's say this stretch
of s and stretch of D G's it is quite
visible giving direct angles right that
go around it but now is it still visible
so I think it is I mean you can see the
stretch of IMG's we can go over the
possible k-mers see that there is a
specific gamer that appeals more times
or appears in each sequence and it's
easy to find it but what happens when we
add for mutations for each of these
sites now when we'll go and look for the
k-mers I'm not sure that we'll discover
that this is an enriched Kaymer the
stretch of a and stretch of this and
it's becoming a more difficult problem
so this is an illustration of why it is
very difficult so I'm going to talk
about the classic solution the meme
algorithm and the teasers
expectation-maximization to solve the
problem and it is the classic problem
that given the sequence set you want to
find the pwm but represent the bangle
sites
so just a short reminder of p.m. I'm not
going to prove anything about it so II
am will giving us input incomplete data
originating from probability
distribution and we have some known
parameters and we want to learn these
parameters in a way that maximizes the
likelihood now we MLPs in this in this
way to find the parameters that maximize
the likelihood but it does so by finding
a local maximum not necessarily the
global maximum so you may want to start
from different positions yeah all the
initial guesses of the parameters and
then maximize install TM and the setting
of VM is that we have data X this is the
data we have in our hands we can observe
it and we have some even information Y
that we don't know if we add Y we could
compute the parameters that give the
maximum likelihood we want to find the
parameters and the main component in
a.m. is the Q function this is a
reminder I think for most of you here we
have the complete log likelihood of the
data so it's the probability of x and y
the data that we have ended in
information given the parameters and Q
is the expectation over the distribution
of Y then an information of the complete
log likelihood now the algorithm works
so first we do this thing iteratively we
first calculate the Q function and then
we want to find the parameters that
maximize the Q function and what e/m
gives us is a guarantee that with each
step we improve the likelihood but then
we are not sure when to stop so the most
common practice is to stop when the
improvement is too small but it does not
mean that we necessarily hit the global
maximum we could read the local maximum
and and and we may improve later on much
more but when to stop any M is a
research topic by itself and I'm not
to cover it here this is what is done is
usually done for
expectation-maximization what do we do
for the problem of finding motifs so the
data that we are giving our all
overlapping Ellmers in the input
sequences so we can take the sequences
and broke break them into Ellmers then
we assume that each of these Ellmers is
generated by evil model one or model 2
so what is the first model the first
model is the motif model it is generated
by a position white matrix so we have a
CG NT in each position each cell in that
matrix we have f i-b because the
probability of observing be at position
I of the model so when Elmer can be
generated from such a matrix or it can
be generated from a background model so
I write this is mother one model two is
just a vector for ACGT
we have the probability of observing to
be in the background distribution in the
promoter region in the region that is
outside the binding site and we also
have the parameters lambda 1 lambda 2
that give us the probability that an
Elmer is from model 1 or from model T so
we want to learn these parameters these
parameters in lambda 1 lambda 2 and we
assuming independence between the
Ellmers and although this is not all
simplicity we can assume that now what
is the missing data that we have in this
problem we don't know if an Elmer is
generated by model 1 or modeled by the
motif model or the background model and
if we add this information we could
actually solve the problem very easily
to just take all of the binding sites
because we know they are binding sites
calculate the frequency in each position
and we are done so the complete
likelihood in this case would be the
probability of X and Z given the
parameters
now since the excise the Ellmers are
independent we can have it as a
multiplication of all of those of X I
and that I given the parameters theta
and lambda and now we can use the chain
rule and calculate the probability of
observing excite giving Z I so given the
line we know if it is from other one or
model 2 so we can calculate the
probability of observing that Elmer and
then we have to multiply by the
probability of Z I so if Z is it's an
indicator variable so if it is 1 we have
this probability and if it if the other
model if that i2 equals 1 then we have
this probability now when we applied the
log on this complete likelihood and we
have it as a sum and since this is an
indicator variable we can just multiply
it by the write probability so that IJ
is equal 0 or 1 and when it's 1 it
multiplies the correct probability the
the complete log likelihood of the
problem now we are going to calculate
the expectation of the log likelihood
I'm going to start with some guess of
theta in lambda then repeat until
convergence of theta well we re estimate
Z from the current parameters those of
iteration T then we going to maximize
and estimate the parameters for the next
round and from X and Z and then we'll
repeat those steps for various guesses
of theta n lambda so the expectation
that we take is only over the digestion
over the distribution of the hidden
information and the only information
that we have is in that is the indicator
variable that's the only random variable
in our case this is constant so we can
take it out of the expectation and now
we need to calculate the expectation of
z IJ prime let's say let's denote the
expectations at IJ prime since this is
an indicator variable the expectation is
the probability it is equal to one and
then using the chain rule chain rule
again this is we can have it as the
probability of it equal to 1 and of
excited run probability over the
probability of X I and now it splits
using the rule of the total probability
so we have the probability that it said
I J equals 1 and X I over the
possibilities that it is from the first
model and the second model so just to
give an intuition quite simply it's like
we have the probability that it is the
that the Aylmer is from the third is
from the first model if you want to
calculate that it is from the first
model over the probability that it is
from the first and the second so this is
the relative weight for being in that
model we can calculate for the first and
the second models this is a bit of
mathematics now we want to maximize it
so we have the expectation so I'll just
give an example of us I will find the
lambda
and I won't go over data so in this case
since the log breaks up the
multiplication as a sum we only have to
consider and we only want to maximize
depending on lambda we can only consider
this part of the sum and so we know that
lambda 1 plus lambda 2 equals to 1 so we
can replace lambda 2 by 1 minus lambda 1
now we just have to derive write to find
the value that gives us the maximum in
all these mathematics and arithmetic
I'm sure all of you can do that it and
we set it to 0 and we find out that the
new lambda 1 is going to be the sum of
all the theta 1 prime over N so if you
can think about this is the most
intuitive thing to do we go over the
expectation that each elmer belongs to
model 1 we sum over these expectations
and and divide it by n so that gives us
the new probability that an Elmer is
from the first model and similarly we
can have it for the second model I mean
if we add Zed and we didn't have to have
the expectation of said then that's the
way we would calculate lambda 1 and
lambda 2 so it's very intuitive and
similarly we have we can find out how to
update theta to the next iteration and
this would be the expected number of
times seed JK is the expected number of
times that letter K is produced at
column J so we have that expected number
of times over the number of times each
one of the letters appears in that
position ACGT
so this is also something that is very
intuitive in that we would do if we had
all the data if we had said and the way
to calculate the expected number of
times is again using this set so once we
calculated that already we can use it to
update parameters this is quite straight
fold and you can do the mathematics so
maybe you have already seen them in one
of the courses that you have taken so
this is one example of finding one
motive and if we want to find multiple
motives the common practice is just to
mask the one that we find and then to
start the process again and if we see a
big decrease in the like
of the model then it tells us that maybe
the next motif that we found is a false
motif but up till then we found true
motives just to comment about meme this
wasn't the computational aside it's I
think the most popular tool that there
is out there and I just discussed with
Steven that one of the wonderful things
and features it has a user friendly
website that biologists can go and plug
in their sequences and generate a motif
and it's very fast they don't have to
control the parameters and in the end
you get this interpretable sequence
logos that they could they can put in
their papers and it still I think the
most use motif finding algorithm out
there all Vodun have been other
algorithms throughout the years that how
to perform it but see I think what at
least my impression is that what most
biologists need is a nice model that
represents the band preferences it
doesn't necessarily have to be the most
accurate but something that they can
later represent and and also get
understand something about the biology
behind the process but it's still an
open problem and many comprehension and
challenges about notifying because many
of those motif finding tools find false
positives and and we don't always have
the way to evaluate the false positive
rate and what is true and what is not
I don't know how much it controls the
false positive rate it might be I mean
but usually what you do in this case you
try from different starting points yes I
don't have an answer how many starting
points how much it has an effect on the
false positive rate today meme is is a
part of a big meme suit that has many
tools that you can see here so some of
form of this discovery meme is here a
dream which is for discriminative motive
finding here it's the problem where we
are given a set of sequences which are
believed to be bound and a set of
sequences which are believed to be
unbound so we have to define to find the
discriminative motif
other tools for example TomTom to find
similarity of a PWM to other pwms and
there are many other tone so it's quite
a successful suit of tools so that was
the conclusion of the first part
reminder of meme algorithm and so maybe
if anyone is question about meme if not
I can go on to the next part and so this
will be something completely new the
data and the computational challenges
and solutions so it is time to wake up
and the second part I'm going to talk
about something that was part of my PhD
thesis was discovering motifs in high
throughput in vitro data really
something that a technology that
transformed the field of gene regulation
and the community that grows after these
binding models and pushed it forward was
the invention of development of protein
binding macros from multiple except from
Harvard and this was I think the first
time that we can really get in high
throughput and in vitro the intrinsic
DNA preferences binding preferences of a
protein so what is this technology about
we start from a sequence the design of a
sequence that covers each DNA 10 mer
exactly once and if if anyone is
familiar with the brain sequences this
is how we can get such a sequence now we
take this long sequence and we chop it
up into pieces of 36 base pairs with
overlapping by 9 base pairs so we don't
lose any tenure and then this gives us
the design of the microarray now we grow
double-stranded DNA in each spot so each
spot on the micro I now has a different
sequence and we know what sequence it is
and using a fluorescence AIDS we can
measure how much DNA we have in each
spot we can take a protein which we
purify and Express beforehand let it
bind the microarray and use the
fluorescence antibody
to give us the banging intensity to each
of those sequences you can imagine what
kind of an improvement it is that we
don't have any of the factors that
involved in in vivo binding now we have
just in
we throw a clear signal of what the
protein likes to bind it is to a short
sequence of 36 base pairs not these long
promoters regions or chipset Peaks and
it is solely due to a direct a
transcription factor binding what is the
data that we see as computational people
we can go to a public database download
one experiment which gives us the
binding intensity of a single protein to
many of those sequences in you we need
to experiment we have around 41,000
probes each of 36 base pairs and the
corresponding binding intensity so this
is the data between the computational
people go and download from the database
this day is a unit of data base from a
tabular Club even contains more than 400
experiments covering proteins from
different model organisms and also a
team used lab from the University of
Toronto as the SBPD database that has
more than 1000 of those PBM experiments
so it's really a lot of data it's all
publicly available so what is the
computational challenge in this case so
we have done one experiment we've got
the data and if each sequence was the
complete binding site then we will done
right because we have the intensity to
each of the binding sites that's what we
want to measure but the sequences are
still a bit low of 36 base pairs and
usually the binding site is around 810
maybe 15 base pairs so we need to
identify the short binding sites in
those probe sequences and from this data
we need to come up again with the
compact model of the binding preferences
this is the computational challenge that
we want to tackle first I'll describe
one simple algorithm from our lab and
then it was also implemented and used I
mean it was implemented independently in
team in team use lab and I think it is
very simple and still very effective so
first we are giving the sequences and we
want to give a score for each gamer so
what's called we give we just calculate
the average Bank intense
so we see tcga appearing four times and
with these intensities we calculate the
average and this is the score that we
give to this camera we do this to each
camera now here in this illustration the
size of K the value of K is four but
what we really do is use K equals eight
or nine and we cannot do more than that
and the reason is is that if you recall
in the design of the microarray each DNA
10 mer appeared exactly once so we
cannot get an accurate statistics for 10
Mars or more than 10 rez but we can get
a good statistics for 9 miles or 8 mils
8 Mills already appealed 30 times so you
can have an aggregate statistics over
all eight Mars which is quite robust so
we have this calculation and the idea
behind using the average binding
intensity is if it is a real binding
site in all of its occurrences that will
appear with high intensity because the
protein likes to bind that binding site
that sequence but if it is a non binding
site it may have one appearance with a
binding site in the same probe sequence
but in most occurrences it will probably
be with other non binding sites so it
will have a low bang intensity in most
of its occurrences so we'll get a low
average so this is the idea behind using
an average and it works quite well and
now we are giving this list of k-mers
which gives us a score for each k-mer
now if we are interested in a kml model
that represent the bank preferences
between we are done because we have the
cameras and the scores but we'd like to
now fold it into a more compact position
weight matrix model but we cannot just
take this cassette and fold it because
as you see there are some shifts in this
in the list for example the second one
is the TI 80 starting from the second
position so we have to do an alignment
all right so we would have to take the
second one and move it to the left we
have to
and the filled Kaymer move it one
position to the right now moving two
positions here and this one can stay in
place and so on and we are done and we
can take about 500 or top one thousand
eight mares now in general multiple
sequence alignment is a difficult
problem but this is a very easy problem
because the alignment is always to the
top eight mil which we observed is
always different sense of sequence so
the technology is very robust in finding
the consensus sequence and we can align
the rest of the camels only in reference
to the top Kaymer so it's a very simple
I meant no gaps just eight base pairs we
can do it very quickly and then we can
look at each position and deduce the
probabilities of that column using the
scores that we have here so it's a very
simple algorithm it takes a couple of
seconds to run the data and produces
accurate models now I'm going to move to
another algorithm which is called the B
ml PBM and this is considered the
state-of-the-art and the difference here
in this model that is it is based on a
biomechanical model of protein DNA
binding so in the next slides I'm going
to present the model and how it is used
in this algorithm the parameters of the
model are learned using some
optimization from minimization procedure
so any interaction in this case in
interaction between a protein and a DNA
sequence can be represented by two
values the K on and K off which are the
on rate and off rate of the interaction
so it is the rate that we have these two
molecules and and they start to bind and
we have them bound all the rate that we
have a bound complex and we say
dissolved into the two ingredients and a
way to take into account both K often KN
is having their ratio which is termed a
KD so this value represents the absolute
binding affinity of a protein to a DNA
sequence and if we have all the k ds so
if for specific protein we have the k ds
for all of the possible DNA k-mers we
can really get the affinities to each
DNA sequence but this is a property of
the protein and these are quite hard to
measure these KD values because they
depend on the TF concentration which is
how to measure and so on so how is it
taken into account in the model so the
probability of binding in equilibrium so
all of these values in equilibrium and
what does it mean in equilibrium it
means that the concentration of bound
and unbound DNA is the same so the
probability is the ratio between the
bound DNA over the bound and unbound DNA
right it makes sense because we have the
bound divided by the bound and unbound
this gives the probability for sequence
now we can divide both the denominator
and Dominator by the concentration of
the d of the bound DNA and we get this
value now if you recall this is K off of
LK on time's the concentration of the TF
and we can also replace it with KD and
as I said we have a problem of measuring
this KD over the concentration of the TF
we have a problem of measuring absolute
affinities we don't know how much
protein in fact was applied to the
microarray and was able to bound the DNA
so what we can measure our specificities
so while affinities give us an ability
to compare between different protein
specificities gives us an ability to
compare between different sequences
given that they are bound by the same
protein so for specific protein we can
have the relative binding to different
sequences so now we have its value 1
over 1 plus CI new will mu old the KD of
some reference sequence it can be the
consensus sequence or some other
sequence this is the concentration of
the TF and AI is the binding model which
I'm going to expand in the next slide so
we need to both learn the parameters of
VI and the from a term u so what is the
I yeah the energy contribution where the
PWM model can be so represented as a PWM
for example so here it's a
multiplication of the different
positions in the PWM model
giving the base bill of assign position
k and epsilon of that base parent
position k gives us the energy
contribution in that position for that
baster and we can try different models I
mean we can apply the PWM we can apply
PWM plus dinucleotide features we can
have a came a model so really we can
play with the parameters and now we want
to represent the energy contribution of
of the sequences and rig out we have a
reference sequence now we should also
consider the reverse complement double
stranded nature of DNA sequence so the
probability bank-robber leti two double
stranded si is the probability of mining
to si plus the probability of not
binding to it but binding to its reverse
complement so this is model so this is
incorporated in this equation and now as
I said we have sequences of 36 base
pairs so we go with a window of length L
over that sequence and take the
probability of each subsequent of length
L in that sequence and this gives us the
total probability of a probe sequence so
we have a sequence of 36 base pairs and
let's say we want to our model is of a
size 10 so we just sum over all elmer's
of size 10 in that sequence this is the
sameer now what is really done in the
algorithm is that they take into account
some bias in the data which is called
the positional bias so if you recall I
told you about the microwave technology
wave we have the probe sequences on the
glass so apparently it is harder for the
protein to go into the glass and bind
the binding sites which is closer to the
glass it's easier for it to bind the
binding site when it is up not close to
the surface this is a positional bias
inside the probe sequence so we can add
the weight here that represents this
positional bias very aristocrat 'm of
calculate the position of bias I mean if
we look at position 0 to 36 so 0 would
be hard and then it the Bank sites the
Bank intensity improves and goes down a
bit this is how it looks in practice
so we have the estimates by the model
which is the B of di of the sequence TI
we have the measured intensity so now we
can fit the parameters to the observed
intensity then we can apply one of the
algorithms to do this minimization and
we also have a term that regulates the
PWM not to overfit the data to be to the
generate so this is an additional term
over the position weight matrix model so
this is bimmel and PBM it's a quite
effective algorithm and it is considered
the state of the art so just one slide
on the results and a comparison between
the algorithm I've presented a couple
here
I presented rep this is the sequence
logo it generates and be Mallett
represents here and what we see in
general for different proteins is that
the sequence log is the track comes up
with and also see the mobile are more
interpretable they have these more
strict letters higher letters if you
look at the sequence level so this is
one advantage of rep of a beaming PBM
which produces these more degenerate
models which are harder to interpret and
understand what are the binding
preferences in terms of accuracy b-mail
and drape on power on the same level so
though as accurate there is one point
that I want to mention in the comparison
of different algorithms we compare them
using PBM data so we took a model from
PBM data and then predicted another
experiment from PBM on the same protein
this is in vitro binding prediction but
we also took the model and try to
predict in vivo binding and we could
validate and go to the performance of
our loop do the prediction using in vivo
data chip chip or chip SEC and you see
that the performance decreases
significantly from in vitro to in vivo
this is I think is still one of the
challenges of the community how to take
these in vitro models I mentioned it
before and and apply them to in vivo de
and I think Nadav mentioned the few
technologies that give us additional
data such as epigenetic data nucleosome
occupancy and so on that we can add and
supplement our binding models to improve
binding prediction but I think this is
still the goal that the community
strives to achieve and it's still an
open challenge so well we did not
because we take the average mining
intensity so we kind of assume that if
we average over it it will come out
there right so I mean just by random
probability you have the binding sites
appearing in different position so by
the average you kind of lose this
problem this was observed by us and
other people as well
okay so what is the next technology as
you know in by informatics we have
technology is evolving all the times and
and and once you have the new technology
the previous one might be obsolete so I
just want to mention the next technology
in the computational solutions for it
and some of the open problem is industry
and that in applying and analyzing the
data coming from this technology so this
technology is called the highfalutin
SELEX and you heard about cervix or a
fabric so cervix has been around from
the 90s and the finger if cervix is that
you want to measure a specificity in in
this case you want to measure to what
sequences does the protein bind so we
can start with four random set of
sequences that the protein bind take out
those that were bound and and now take
the set of sequences and reiterate the
process so we reiterate the process
several cycles and we get an exponential
enrichment of the protein DNA binding
specificity so this the exponential
enrichment goes into the name SELEX so
in the it starts has been in the past
with us since the 90s but in the past we
can only do Sanger sequencing so we left
with a few sequences in the last round
the pre boot sequence and get a few of
the binding sites but now if I put
sequencing we could do the same process
but now we can sequence each round and
do - but not Sanger sequencing but we
can sequence thousands and millions
sequences in each round and what we get
in the output so we do this iteration
this process that we let the protein
bind we take out the bound sequences we
sequence them and we reiterate the
process with the new sequences we get
the sequence file this is the output of
the experiment so how does it look like
in the data let's say that in red we
have the binding sites so as we go from
cycle to cycle we've seen enrichment of
that binding sites and that's what we
want to capture the preference the DNA
binding preference of the protein and we
hope that I mean the felt cycle should
be totally random
I may be uniform sequences or close to
uniform sequences and then as we go
through the cycle you see the
specificity
so the computational challenge is to
take this data and again to come up with
a PWM or another binding model so just
to show one advantage of the circus
technology and why it is so why I mean
it's not a it's going we're going to
benefit from it
compelled to PBM data so the fact that
we can generate longer motifs and this
was asked before that indeed the
flanking positions do matter and affect
the TF DNA binding and in PBM we are
limited by these eight positions right
we cannot do more because each enemy
repeals exactly once but here in - put
selects they all egos the DNA sequences
that are used are 40 base pairs so and
we sequence them so we don't have the
same length limit and we can improve the
length if we have more sequences we
increase the sample size so we can
generate these longer sequences longer
motifs and indeed when we try to use
them to predict in vivo binding we see
that they all have better prediction
accuracy so this is just to give
motivation on why we are interested in
using high throughput selects to improve
over PBM so here I'm going I'm going to
give and to show one solution yeah yeah
that was chips accused so we took the
models that were published for PBM and
for hybrid circuits for the same protein
and we use chipset so first this is a
computational analysis that was part of
the Select sex a select sec protocol
from busie MCOs lab and here they first
start with finding the k that they want
to work on right it I mean this is a
program by itself what is the and we
wait for the motif of the model that we
should use the way they do it is using
the KL divergence causal KL divergence
gives us the distance between two
distributions and bits
how many random bits we need to add one
distribution to have
the other and they do that although all
cameras that have a count that is more
than 100 so some cameras don't appear
very very few times so we don't want to
use them but most gamers appear with a
count more than 100 we put them into the
calculation where the distribution that
they compare is the distribution of
cameras here in the second round
compared to the initial run so we start
from a uniform distribution and we all
close to uniform and we go to
distribution that gives us the binding
preferences that is more specific to the
protein binding and we take they take
all comers that have count less than 100
and put them in the same pool which is
legit so they get a distribution and
they can do this calculation of Cal
divergence and where they get the
highest Cal divergence they choose that
K is sort of a way to measure how much
information gain gain we get from
choosing that cake in the last round
compared to the initial round that we
started from and in their example it was
12 so that was the choice of K and then
the scored they Eve did they give for
each Kaymer
is the ratio between the frequency in
the i'f cycle over the ratio in the
initial cycle in the route that is to
the I so like in the power of 1/2 the I
and the idea behind that that from cycle
to cycle if we see a k-mer it it is
multiplied by the same factor from cycle
to cycle so the preference to that
Kaymer competing with other k-mers is
the same factor and this is the factor
that we are trying to figure out here
now what I really do for the initial
cycle is that they don't take the
observed frequency by they estimate them
using a 5th order Markov model since
they claim that they don't have enough
sample size in the initial cycle to have
good accurate frequencies observed in
the data to use the fifth order Markov
model to generate these frequencies for
12 months
which are not that which not appear with
they don't appear with
numbers in the initial cycle so this is
the score that they get for each gamer
and now the if if we want a came a model
we have a list of gamers and the score
if you want a PWM you can apply rap
algorithm or bmail algorithm and get a
PWM using the same cameras and scores so
it's quite that straightforward but what
is still missing be thinking in high
throughput selects analysis first how do
we choose the cycle it's unclear if we
have several cycles so far what everyone
has been doing is choosing one of the
last cycles with no clear rules because
they are given the most they give the
most specific and binding preferences
but maybe we can benefit from looking at
previous cycle no one has been able so
far to utilize several cycles together
so maybe by observing what happens
through the cycle we can come up with
something more accurate about them when
preferences then just looking at a
single cycle and of course with every
technology we have technological biases
so so we need to cover them and as I
mentioned before this is one of the big
challenges that the community of gene
regulation is still trying to solve and
so this just to summarize these two part
that I've discussed so far so I've shown
different models that we can use to
model DNA Bank preferences well the PWM
is currently the most popular and used
I've done a reminder for the meme
algorithm how to use
expectation-maximization to find motifs
and also talked about the new data from
PBM in - put selection about the
computational analysis to perform on
this data to get the same motifs so this
concludes the second part and I'm going
to go into other problems but if someone
has a question about this stuff
could you come in a bit um the meaning
of the weights right so in the Beamer
model it's the energy contribution goes
in that that model that I've shown so
they caught they say it's the energy
contribution of that nucleotide in that
position well in other cases it's the
frequency so this is like a common
weights in other ways to is to have a
low odds ratio in the in each cell so
you have the log and and then it's a way
that you sum over so you have the
frequency of the base be at position I a
you go over the frequency of that base
let's say in the background then you
take the log so that is the logos odds
ratio so how I mean all surprising it is
to see the base given the background
distribution and then you can sum up the
logs and get a score for the binding
sites so these are common weights in
them in the matrix I hope that they
answer you should waste which word
frequencies of the gainer
because they have high values yeah so it
don't have yes some I mean we just
folded it into a distribution so the sum
in each column would be one but it
doesn't have to be necessarily so so
yeah it's no no it's not the frequency
right at the binding intensity yeah so
yeah it's a mixture of buying intensity
followed in the frequency so there is
something about it that we didn't think
about
question about HT sellers do people do
replicates with the same transcription
factor and how similar are they well you
don't care about this sequences about
but on about Kaimal frequencies at the
end because you might start with a
different pool of all the goddesses I
mean it's a random pool so no one has
looked at the exact oligos the 40 base
pairs long goalie goes but they did look
a dick at the Kaymer's so we now a
people compared so they did replicates
Beaufort and we come within compare
replicates but we compared mouse and
human proteins and full proteins
compared to only the binding domains and
we didn't see any significant difference
between the those but we only analyzed
the kml frequencies and not their
complete oliver's looking for something
in there yeah so in that comparison we
didn't see any significant difference
we had paper the animal apply statistics
we got to be tribe to look at the state
of things yeah I can catch you up later
I'll go to the slides which I kept as a
backup and this is a new theoretical
idea how to use the brewing sequences to
for sequence design and assembly and
this is by director de Bruyne and graphs
and ok so does anyone know about by
directed graphs okay so I'll be showing
something again new to the audience just
about the motivation for the problem so
assembly we all know what assembly is
right with reeled from melio and pavel
peasant ER and the sequence designs
coming to play in the PBM technology
right i mentioned that they have a
design will each ten Merapi each and
miracles exactly once the user de bruin
sequence so this will these kind of
problems come into okay so let's start
with the introduction i think most of
you all of you know what is it the
brewing sequence of okay it is a cyclic
sequence that every possible k-mers
appears exactly once this is the
sequence that used for the PBM
technology it is the most compact
sequence well indeed every each camera
feels exactly once and so the length is
the size of sigma the alphabet to the k
in our case it's default nucleotide so
it's fall to decay and there is an
example of the brewing sequence of order
to write if you want to check me you can
go over the sequence and see that indeed
every possible dinucleotide among the
six in dinucleotides appears in this
sequence how do we generate the brewing
sequence the one way to do it is using
the broom graphs there is an example of
different graph of order one and what we
have in the graph is every vertex as a
label of a k-mer so we have a sigma and
the size of sigma to decay Kaymer's
every edge directed edge is an overlap
as we all mentioned in his talk so it
means that we have an overlap of K minus
1 between the source and the target
vertex so the number of edges is the
size of Sigma to the k plus 1 and we get
the in degree and out degree
and both are equal to the size of the
alphabet and as the fact that we get at
the pre graph is strongly connected and
each vertex is balanced and if you
recall from algorithms 101 this means
that the graph is Eulerian and we
couldn't perform an Euler two over the
graph that means that it covers this
Euler tools gives us the brewing
sequence of order k plus 1 so this is
one way to generate in linear time at
the brewing sequence here in this
example you see the brewing graph of
order 1 each nucleotide is represented
as a node in all possible dinucleotides
our edges in the graph so other ways to
generate just as a comment the prune
sequences are linear feedback shift
registers and one elde about them and
our recursive ways to generate those but
this is a very useful way ok so how do
we ask them do assembly by the Brynn
graphs and I mean we look at the reads
we have the set of cameras that appears
in the reads we can construct the Brewin
graph and have the edges represent the
k-mers and then we can perform an oil
800 2 and find the sequence that
connects all of these cameras together
now is it always possible so not
necessarily depends of the set of
cameras that we have in the data and
what we have to do in case it is not
strongly connected or of course if it's
not strongly connected then we have to
have we have to work on its on the
connected component independently but if
not all of the vertices are balanced
then we have to cover some of the
cameras or the edges several times in
order to go and cover all cameras so
what our aim is to have a sequence one
sequence that covers all the cameras
that we see in the data so we can solve
it using the Chinese postman the
solution to the Chinese postman problem
I didn't know what white was called the
Chinese postman problem but one Chinese
student said that it's a big problem
that they learn in China and it's
because Chinese mathematician studied
and gave the solution
this is the case and what is the problem
of the postman it has to go over each
road and the level domain right and it
it takes to go over each road so each
road or street is represented as an edge
in the graph and it stays to go over and
deliver the mail it may go over road
several times so find the shortest path
the traverses each edge at least one so
we may have weights on the edges they
can represent if it is like Kaymer's
from the data the coverage of the kml or
the likelihood of that Kaymer so we have
weights and one two shortest path and it
can be solved by minimum cost flow so we
can define as a set V - all the vertices
with greater in degree and with V plus
all the vertices with greater out degree
then we can have the capacity from the
source to all of the v- vertices be the
imbalance so this is the number of edges
that will need to go over all to add to
have them balanced and similar similarly
from the vertices in V plus to the
target and all of the rest of the
original edges can have a capacity of
that is unbounded we can go over them as
much as we want what is the cost of
different edges so those that go to from
the soles or to the target can have a
cost of zero we know how much flow is
going to pass through them but all the
rest is the original weight that is part
of their problem I mean the cost of
traversing the street or the likelihood
of a k-mer or so on then after we found
in the minimum cost flow what we do is
we can add for each edge UV and the
number of copies of that edge according
to the flow that passes through that
edge so that fixes the balance problem
for each vertex
this is the Chinese postman there is
some about how we can solve the problem
of minimum cost flow using successive
shortest paths they give her several
bounds of how to find the shortest path
and so on now
so far I haven't described anything new
because we know to do assembly we know
that most of the assembly algorithms
walk in this way how can we improve so
we have to consider the reverse
complement the double strand is property
of DNA which means that we have a k-mer
we also have the reverse complement of
the camer
so in this example if we have this
sequence we also observe this sequence
and as I say here in a double strand
sequence when we have the cam and we
have its reverse complement so the goal
is to find the shortest sequence to
cover all the k-mers now a kml can
appear as itself always it's reverse
complement so it doesn't necessarily we
have to cover the camels as they are and
data so maybe we can find an even
shorter double-stranded DNA sequence
that covers all the camer that we
observed in the data and one way to do
it is using by director deploying graphs
which I'm going to introduce soon and
I'm going to give a solution to the
problem using linear programming and
also using the bipartite graph now also
describe an application to the design of
the PBM probe sequences so what is a bi
directed graph okay I should have this
erased
room to write some of the definitions
this is a new notion to some of you so
ear each edge end point as an
organization okay so here we're in the
example we say that we have X and then
this kind of orientation is a negative
orientation and the orientation of each
beam respect to X is positive
now each edge point is this orientation
and the incidence matrix values of minus
two integer values from minus 2 to 2
which is for each edge if it has two
negative endpoints it is minus 2 if it's
2 positive it is 2 and can be anything
in between now the in degree is the sum
of all of the all of the edges that have
a negative endpoint and this is all of
the edges that have a m+ and the balance
is the out degree minus the in degree as
we know and also the sum of all the
incidence matrix is gives us the balance
of each no this is by directed graphs
how does it relate to double-stranded
DNA so just before I go on to that the
Brewin graphs and now we use that so a
walk now is not the same as a path in a
directed graph now a walk follows as to
follow these rules so it is still a
series of vertices interleaved by edges
well AI is incident to X I and X I plus
1 but the edge has to follow the rule
that AI minus 1 and E is opposite
orientation at X I so this is an example
of a walk so we have W and then a and X
then we go out of B so here a entered
with a negative orientation and xx out
we went out of X and B with a positive
orientation so this follows the rules
and this is considered a walk in a by
directed graph this for example is not a
walk so we go to aid and 2 X into this
so this is negative and this is negative
orientation so this is not a walk so we
have to remember that we don't have
paths as we know from directed graphs of
two wave walks so what are by directed
de bruin graphs so in the original de
bruin graph each were each node here
represented a k-mer now each node is
going to represent
and it's reverse complement so that's
the addition and that's why it's so
useful when we want to do assembly and
consider both strengths and also for
sequence design and there are some rules
about what is the label of this edge so
for example if a is positive 2x so we
have here that it is positive here and
negative y know so this is positive to
both of them is positive 2x and positive
2y then P x80 overlaps and y which is TT
okay so this rule walked we have so the
label here would be a TTT a TT and right
so I won't write on the wall don't call
this is going to be a TT and the reverse
complement is a a T this is the label of
this edge listen now each note as well
as each edge represents a k-mer and it's
reverse complement so what can we how
can we solve the Chinese postman problem
so again we take the k-mers that we saw
in the data we put them on the edges we
put each Kaymer as an edge in the graph
now what we have to solve is the minimum
cost flow and we can do this using
linear programming so we want to
minimize the number of flow that we put
times the cost of traversing the floor
for G and this is subject such that the
flow that we had fixes the balance right
we had the imbalance in each node that
we wanted to fix so we have an Euler -
in the graph so we can have this
constraint that the flow that will now
process through the edges is to fix the
imbalance for each one of the vertices
of course the flow is to be non-negative
I can run this and get the solution to
the problem and get the shortest
double-stranded DNA sequence that covers
all comers so there are some technical
details about the LP and the fact that
we are getting it to approximation using
this notion
and in fact we can do it in an optimal
way and polynomial time if we look at
the following by directed graph so let's
do it here on the board
we made the set of sequences that aid in
balancing the telly greater in degree we
had a set of vertices greater our degree
and we need to fix the balance and the
only way we can fix this balance is by
adding a path from a node here a node
here right and then we add an edge here
we had an edge here so we fix the
imbalance for each of those by plus one
I mean so now and the imbalance is
reduced by one for each of those so we
need to find this shortest paths then
all we need to do is a bipartite
matching between these vertices and
these vertices the imbalance of these
and the imbalance of this then we can
solve the problem in polynomial time
given that we have a solution for the
bipartite matching problem for the
weighted bipartite machine this is in
fact what's written here and the only
thing that we need to consider is that
we are talking about vai directed graph
so now finding the shortest path is
slightly different but in fact it's
almost the same algorithm that instead
of looking for example for the Dijkstra
algorithm that finds the shortest path
instead of you can get the shortest of
any neighbor that we can go in the next
edge we have to consider neighbors that
are consistent with a walk as I told you
now we don't have paths where this walks
so we can compute the shortest path
between these vertices in these ones and
then we can solve it using a bipartite
matching this gives us an optimal
solution in polynomial time and then
once we have added these edges by the
flow we can find an Euler tour and find
the shortest double-stranded DNA
sequence that covers all these cameras
so here it's a bit above the wrong time
I'll go over it these are common
algorithms that we know from graph
algorithms
on run in polynomial time now it is
related to the sequence design problem
for PBM right so this is what I talked
about gene regulation in a PBM
technology we have a coverage of each
DNA 10 mer exactly once so in fact we
can reduce the number of probe sequences
we have in coverage that for each DNA 10
mer ever covers the DNA 10 ml all it's
reverse complement does not need to
cover both of them that's where that way
we can have a reduction by half of the
number of probes that we can use in the
technology and maybe we can increase it
to K equals 11 instead of 10 now that we
have more space on the array oh we can
add more sequences of something that we
want to measure so there is a high
incentive to have a more compact and
efficient design so for odd K the graph
they buy directed the brewing graph is
balanced every node in that graph is
balanced and here is an example of one
node and the edges that are incident to
it but for even K there are few nodes
that are unbalanced the problem comes
from palindromes this is something that
we all asked about yesterday what is the
problem with even K 1 and 2 is that we
have the palindromes the reverse
complement palindromes so here ACGT
is the reverse complement of itself for
that reason if you build a graph it will
have a positive orientation at both of
these end points and now this node is no
longer balanced ok so now we want to
apply the same algorithm as we just did
for the assembly problem to fix the
imbalance of the nodes in this graph so
we can apply the same polynomial time
algorithm and then solve the problem we
in fact can do it in a more efficient
trying time because all of the weights
are integers and
can improve the running time of Dijkstra
and and the bipartite matching just to
show you the computational results for
so comparing between the brewing
sequence and a reverse complement the
brewing sequence so I don't show any
results for odd K because for these
cases the length was just reduced by
half but for the even cake cases where
we had to do this fixed because of
palindromes we see that we have a
reduction that is almost by half its
approaching F as K increases we have the
numbers so in practice we are able now
to give a design that reduces number of
probes by half both or even K and odd K
and this is an optimal solution for both
case for any value of K okay so some
open questions so there is also some
interest and that was done in the
original design of PBM technology to
cover a gap game ears so can we improve
that because here I only considered
continuous k-mers what is the number of
reverse complement the brewing sequence
so here this is the equation for all
possible the brewing sequences and just
for theoretical interest I mean I don't
think it is any application or relevance
to the technology or biology well we can
ask the same question can we ever design
that minimizes the number of probes that
cover the set of cameras because in the
solution that I introduced we find one
Euler tool that covers all cameras
together so this is one sequence that we
then have to chop up and use astros but
since the technology already uses the
set of probes can we or design the
probes directly without going through
one long signals and can we suggest a
linear time algorithm
because the polynomial ate some it was a
concave fall to the 3k over to maybe we
can improve that to the fall to the K
and then can we come up with a closed
formula to the length because these all
of these values are from empirical test
I mean and the algorithm and we got the
result okay so I think this this is a
reference for the last part but this
concludes the talk I've got to talk
about three parts about the motif and in
game above the sequence design problems
and yeah so I'll be happy to take
questions and thanks for listening
questions